of course gun laws are different in
every state but with all of these
shootings all across the country and the
different circumstances of each we did
want to take a step back and assess some
of the numbers so listen to this there
are nearly 434 million firearms in
civilian possession Nationwide these are
your friends and neighbors your fellow
Americans that's according to a firearm
industry trade Association what it means
is that there are roughly 100 million
more guns in the country than there are
people in the country and as far as the
three states that Mark Strassman just
mentioned Alabama and Missouri well they
have the fourth and Ninth highest
firearm mortality rates in the country
respectively and Texas it has the
heaviest burden of gun deaths in this
country deaths by gun violence 4 600 a
year and that is only good enough in
that state for 27th as a mortality rate
middle of the pack think about that and
all three of those States no permit is
required to purchase a rifle to purchase
a shotgun or to purchase a handgun
now to a major development in the
federal investor investigation into
Hunter Biden's tax returns an attorney
for an IRS supervisor is sending a
letter to lawmakers today asking for
whistleblower protection for his client
he's alleging the investigation is being
improperly influenced by quote
preferential treatment and politics our
chief investigative correspondent Jim
Axelrod is here with more Jim good
morning good morning Nate we are
learning more about this potential
whistleblower described by his attorney
as a nonpartisan career civil servant
who's looking for protections to share
what he's experienced
my client wants to come forward to
Congress he's ready to be questioned
about what he knows and what he
experienced under the proper legal
protections attorney Mark ladle's client
is a supervisory special agent at the
IRS
is prepared to tell Congress the
investigation he's been working on has
been hampered by what he thinks his
special treatment typical steps that a
law enforcement investigator would take
were compromised because of political
considerations Lytle wouldn't talk in
specifics declining to identify either
his client or the target of the
investigation his client helped conduct
can you identify him I can't at this
stage Jim but CBS News has learned the
investigation The Whistleblower worked
on is about Hunter Biden what we're
doing is is being completely Cooperative
that was Biden two years ago after the
doj opened an investigation into his
finances the FBI collected what it
believed was sufficient evidence to
charge Biden with tax crimes and last
year sent its findings to the U.S
attorney in Delaware since then silence
Why can't your client talk to us
directly at this point there are laws
that provide protection into
whistleblowers and he has to navigate
that yesterday lydo sent this letter to
Congress claiming his client could
provide information that would
contradict sworn testimony by a senior
political appointee I have promised to
ensure that he's able to carry out his
investigation CBS News has learned that
was attorney general Merrick Garland who
gave testimony about the Trump appointed
U.S attorney in Delaware conducting the
hunter Biden investigation
Lytle says neither he nor his client are
motivated by politics would you find any
evidence or allegation of a political
agenda no to him the truth is one truth
and he wants to come forward with it
Ladle told us the Whistleblower has been
with the IRS for more than a decade and
has extensive documentation to support
his allegations the things he's been
through are are very well documented in
emails and other Communications with the
Department of Justice
we asked later if there's a chance his
client can only see his slice of the
investigation and not the big picture
Lytle said that's possible but that his
client had expressed his concerns to
superiors a number of times before
seeking whistleblower status neither the
IRS department of justice nor a lawyer
for Hunter Biden would comment to be
continued for sure thank you Jim